[Music]
well I want to get your take on some
Hollywood splits and Chris Pratt and on
a ferry so this is really hard cuz I'm
close to them I'm upset about it I was
the day it happened I actually texted
them I don't know what happened there
he's still living in the house
let's pray it turns around I want them
to get back together so I'm not I'm not
fixing them up I'm just like I would be
the counselor in between I'm going what
really is the issue I would be like what
cuz she's living in the house I really
want them to get back together because
that was my favorite couple we saw you
you commented on her Instagram he said I
love you both yeah I love them both I
mean I don't feel like I don't feel
there I feel like it's communication and
has nothing to do with him being bigger
than her but it could be like he's not
in town with her she's ratings and
raising the kid alone and there could be
issues with that they're very grounded
and down to earth I've been to their
house so were you surprised by that yes
very very shocked actually I'm there for
them and I just love you both and I just
pray that it's gonna work out I told
them don't listen don't listen to the
media don't listen to the news just do
your thing and see where you land and if
he's still in the house there's hope if
the person doesn't leave the house
there's a lot of hope there that means
they still love each other cuz they're
not poor they look at a condo and
they're like everybody it I mean like
it's just that they don't want to leave
each other there's a lot of bestfriend
factor there they're very close as BFFs
you know we'd heard um some similar
things about Chris and Anna that like it
wasn't you know nobody cheated nothing
like that okay one thing we've heard
that was that maybe she wanted more kids
but he wasn't ready to have more kids I
think it's like he's on his career pack
to make this trajectory to become really
successful at what he does and timing is
off and that could be it and maybe she
feels she's taking care of the kid too
much who looks like Jerry Maguire
skitty's he's so sweet and maybe they're
not they're not on the same page at the
same time but I don't feel like you
can't work it out if the sexual
chemistry is there and the friendship
factors there and they have a kid if you
get the right person to handle it it can
retool itself
[Music]
you